ich habe ja ich habe es vorhin schon
gesagt eine dieser schlagzeilen bei dem
man denkt sich verhört zu haben was
haben sie gedacht ja ich war also auch
geschockt muss ich sagen weil wir müssen
einzigen an bord wenn es seit über 40
jahren im filmbusiness also wer hat
nicht zum ersten mal eine pistole in der
hand oder beziehungsweise wird von einem
waffenmeister dazu angeleitet ich selbst
wäre auch ein western im november in
arizona und ich kann nur sagen dass wenn
man so einen film macht erst einmal
trainiert auch wenn man das gewohnt ist
war mit waffen und im film das auch
schon mal gemacht hat zu schießen
allerdings am set selbst
kommt der waffenmeister und zeigt mir
immer die waffe dass sie leer ist das
heißt also allen ämtern wie man so schön
sagt und dann gibt es den spruch auch
eine lehre waffe ist immer gefährlich
also mann
überprüft das zeigt am alles man nimmt
die waffe und selbst wenn man die szene
spielt dann
dann legt man nicht an und zielt auf
seinen gegenüber sondern man hat immer
so 10 15 zentimeter daneben die kamera
kann das trotzdem einfangen von daher
ist das also
ich muss sagen fast schon gut sie schon
fahrlässig an weil
jeder der waffenmeister nochmals wird
keine waffen an einen schauspieler
abgeben die geladen ist und
überprüft das schießt sogar noch zeigt
sie und der schauspieler selbst erhält
sie
auf und hält sie auch zur seite zum
größten teil und wenn er das nicht macht
dann verstößt er gegen alle wege können
sie sich vorstellen warum das in diesem
fall ja offensichtlich nicht passiert
ist warum da eine geladene waffe so wie
es aussieht losgegangen ist warum all
diese sicherheitsvorkehrung nicht
gegriffen haben können sie dass sich das
irgendwie erklären
dafür geht nicht einfach los und eine
waffe dann los wenn man damit schießt
und
ist klar an einem set sind immer ist
immer hektik ist immer eine gewisse
spannung man will durch den tag kommen
ist aber das war glaube ich um die
mittagszeit bloß passiert ist
es ist im grunde ja wenn ich jetzt
gerade zurückdenke es bleibt aber immer
zeit man bereitet sich auch die szene
vor und nochmals alec baldwin hat auch
in anderen actionfilmen geschieht und
und weiß eigentlich damit umzugehen also
ich kann mir nur vorstellen was nämlich
noch wohl wert ist er hat ja ein schuss
kamerafrau wurde erschlossen mit einem
bauchschuss und dann schießt ja auch
noch ein zweites mal wieder ist das die
gleiche kugel die der regisseur
getroffen hat in die schulter oder er
zweimal geschossen ich meine im westen
geht es natürlich auf die szene an die
man gerade macht damit natürlich dann
über folk und dann wird schnell
geschossen und so weiter vielleicht kann
mir nur vorstellen hatte natürlich
unglaublich natürlich dass er eine lehre
waffe also gerne richtig ein paar trauen
drin hatte hat in die richtung glatter
der regisseur in der nähe gestanden von
der kamera also das ist schon mal dass
da wird es ja auch neben dem kameramann
steht und unterhalten was der beste
winkel ist für die szene bei der beide
getroffen wurden und dass zwei getroffen
werden also eine tödlich und der
regisseur verletzt an der schulter wurde
das habe ich noch nie gehört das ist
also bisher noch nie vorgekommen es ist
damals beim brandon lee passiert worüber
fast 30 jahren würden von bruce lee denn
eine löse getötet hat die dann das war
keine kugel aber die hülse waren auch
patron kaspar thronen die hat ihnen dann
tödlich getroffenen herz das war so das
letzte was ich gehört habe ist hier
natürlich immer unfälle in irgendeiner
form mit schusswaffen passt man
besonders darauf
sie drehen ja nun sowohl
den usa als auch hier in europa gibt es
da unterschiede in den
sicherheitsstandards
nicht wenn es zu waffen kommt
selbst wenn man mit waffen
filme gemacht hat sagen wir mal ich hab
jetzt vom jahr oder zwei jahren film
gemacht wo ich mit der waffe geschossen
habe man geht immer wieder auf eine man
wird immer auch wieder unterrichtet man
wird auch gerade jetzt sind die waffen
ja aus der zeit der restzeit war mal um
1860 1870 waren es ja revolver damit
man gibt ganz einfach um auch ein gefühl
dafür zu bekommen auf einer auf einer
ranch gegen zwei drei wochen vorher oder
mit einer winchester man übt das auch
wenn natürlich nachher keine patronen
drin sind aber um ganz einfach mal das
gefühl dazu zu haben
nochmals egal wo auf der welt es gibt
überall einen waffenmeister und der
ist das sind eigentlich große
sicherheitsvorschriften
untergeht her und zeigt und gerade beim
hauptdarsteller halt auch ja da geht man
nochmal in zeigt alex viel zeit mit
genau wie er die szene machen soll also
wir werden wahrscheinlich jetzt in den
nächsten tagen erfahren man das unglück
ist glaube ich gerade erst gestern
passiert
ja das geht jetzt aufgeklärt aber es ist
natürlich auch für den goldring
schlimmer das musste er erst mal
abgesehen für die familien
betroffen sind menschen verloren haben
oder überhaupt für denjenigen der selbst
in dieser situation ist und geschossen
hat wie alec baldwin das ist das ist
schlimm dass das also wer man ist es
kann mir gar nicht vorstellen wenn ich
in die situation da hinein bedingte da
ist das grausamste bald es gibt nur
einen menschen getötet hat oder noch ein
schwerverletzter und
denkbar das ist definitiv keine schöne
situation für den schauspieler aber
jetzt möchte ich noch ganz gerne
also wenn sie sagen tatsächlich kommt er
immer ein waffenmeister und sagt die
pistole ist leer gibt es doch
situationen beim film wo man unbedingt
eine einstellung braucht wo eine patrone
drin ist oder ist das aus ihrer sicht
eigentlich komplett ausgeschlossen
nein es gibt es gibt die ein schlüssel
über dann im hinterteil sehen die sind
durch den special effects also selbst
wenn wir zum beispiel die einschüsse
sehen das wird alles vorher präpariert
es wird mit einer scharfen waffe am set
geschossen also das ist nicht da da
wären dann sonst ins land leute oder
waffenexperten die vielleicht eine szene
außerhalb bis jetzt machen aber am set
selbst
einer scharfen waffe dass das habe ich
noch nie gehören kann warum kann man
nicht einfach mittlerweile gibt ja ich
sage mal spielzeugpistolen die täuschend
echt aussehende warum kann man nicht so
was einfach nutzen wo also definitiv
solche situationen ausgeschlossen sind
naja ich meine diese dieser ball war
benutzt wurden das sind normalerweise
wir haben 66 kugeln
meisten wenn man kann relativ das kommt
auch noch dazu es ist jetzt keine
automatik war in einem modernen film hat
man zum beispiel 15 oder 18 schuss je
nachdem was ist von heckler koch bis zum
essen und so weiter was mich hier
wundert ist dass es ein revolver ist um
1860 der eigentlich wenn öffnest du dann
siehst du a da ist keine kugel drin
guckst du auch noch mal durch das ist
jetzt nicht dass es eine automatische
waffe ist wo schon mal eine
patrone vergessen werden könnte wenn man
das wort obwohl das ist auch eigentlich
unmöglich bei den beiden erwarten
experten prüfen das immer wieder aber
wir reden von einem revolver das heißt
du öffnest das koks einmal normal durch
das ist ganz schnell ist eigentlich
diese das denn mit diesem revolver oder
ich weiß nicht vielleicht hatte auch in
gewähren gewünscht oder irgendwas
benutzt ich kenne die waffe jetzt noch
nicht mitgegangen geschossen hat aber es
sind ja alles sagen wir mal waffen wie
ich auf den modernsten stand sind und da
nimmt man dann hat schon mal natürlich
ein revolver um auch das gewisse gewicht
gefühl zu haben ist eine
spielzeugpistole da
jetzt
könnte man heute kann man alles machen
aber man nimmt da schon echte waffen
aber die keine patronen grün haben und
nochmals selbst dann wenn alles leer ist
und ich gesehen habe dass die waffe mt
ist also dann ziehe ich nicht auf die
person sondern halt immer etwas daneben
und die kamera bitter so einfangen das
ich eben halt also wenn es so aussieht
als wenn ich offiziere aber man zielt
natürlich nicht auf die person das wird
dann immer wieder gesagt ich hab's nicht
anders erleben eine scharfe waffen bin
am set nicht benutzt haben
sie sind quasi in hollywood zu hause
haben sie schon erste reaktionen von
anderen prominenten aus den usa bekommen
ja ich kann bekam jetzt christian auch
aus berlin und bin jetzt hier gerade bei
mir im haus hier in recklinghausen und
ab heute morgen das gelesen und versucht
auch gleich mal den einen oder anderen
auch das land heute ähnlich ein canon
anzurufen was da los ist auch beim
mehrere information hat aber da ist
jetzt ja schlafen der neun stunden
zeitunterschied
ich weise auch perplex ich las dass
heute morgen
bild news und so weiter und auch auf den
amerikanischen sendern hat man es auch
gesehen
das war schockierend
das haben wir damals vor 30 jahren der
prominente person gesagt brandon lee
gewesen in eine höhle getötet hat wird
sich dann
automatische waffe gelöst hat und ihn
natürlich getroffen hat aber bei einem
western kopierer ball haben oder eine
art winchester niemand an und dann
gleich zwei menschen eine tot- und
schwer verletzt ist das habe ich noch
nicht tragischer fall
altrheins herzlichen dank für dieses
gespräch danke für ihre informationen
auch die insiderinformationen so dass
wir uns vorstellen können wie so etwas
am set tatsächlich abläuft dank herr
müller
dann geben
[Musik]